we got into it on the uh the FDR
trying to [ __ ] who was gonna go and I
ended up
winning and then when he drove by me he
took like he had a handful of change and
he just was [ __ ] throwing it at the
side of my car he did it like three
times it was like can you just check on
this side and I'm like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I got his number and I
actually complained it was so funny
because we showed up for the hearing and
by then I wasn't even mad anymore and he
showed up with a lawyer he admitted that
he threw the change at my car but he
said he goes I did it because I look
over and he was looking at me he was
going like this
I don't know what he even said Charlie
he calls you a hack so I was just like
you're telling me I was driving 50 miles
an hour in the rain and I took my hands
off doing that and then that's when the
lawyer jumped in he goes I definitely
have here there's a couple people that
got a little upset that's one of the few
vindictive things I've ever done and I
felt bad